okay guys let's start what do you think
is this aircraft
taking off I just have to move why okay
but flops can be down on take off his
wife yeah it's very hard to tell from
this image yeah probably it's landing
but because there is a gap between the
wings and and the flap and it happens
when the flaps have worked very high a
highly set so this is in Boeing 777 8
handling landing probably this is the
787 trying to stop on the runway you can
see the flaps are down and air brakes
speed brakes are deployed and thrust vs
as well transverse has just pushed the
the air in in the direction of movement
of the aircraft and what's this not so
good this is Turkish Airlines flight
1951 25th or februari 2009 the there was
a fault 40 radio altimeter or on board
and the crew didn't take a good reaction
so in fact they just crashed when a half
kilometers put just before in front of
the runway it was the approach to
Schiphol Airport what we are going to
talk today is how we can prevent these
kinds of things but you can't prevent
these things of these things of
happening because it's due to pilot
error or 40 radio altimeter is the
different instruments but you can do
something else you can see the black box
you see this is orange you usually
people think that it's black but it's
back to Orange because you you want to
easily spot it in nature because nature
is usually blue and green so not so many
orange things in nature it's red orange
and this is real real image of a black
box so my colleague and myself ruff and
me we're going to try to tell you how we
do this how we try to prevent these
things of happening and we are going to
do whatever we can to do that so the
first I'll tell you something about what
the flight data monitoring is
then I'll teach you how to become flight
data analyst in one minute you'll see
some real data coming from black box and
we'll talk about just a bit about engine
health monitoring and will pose the
problem and hopefully we'll bring rough
on the stage and he'll solutes solve the
problem we're not sure but we'll try to
do that ok it's very hard to condense
everything in aviation just one
presentation so flight data monitoring
is just what the title is saying to you
that you have to monitor your flights
why you want to find deviations from the
safety operation so the idea is to make
flying safer it should be non-punitive
because you can have a sensation of
brick Big Brother sensation because the
pilots have to give away their data in
fact they don't do that voluntarily it's
a mandatory thing so looking at how they
fly the planes so imagine when looking
at your data coming from your car and
you just say okay you are sacked because
you just had a like you speed it up on
or under motorway so you shouldn't be
punitive and you will run out of pilots
very soon if you do that and it's data
is very very very confidential quite
sensitive data and the problem is that
it's sometimes it belongs to pilot
sometimes it belongs to the airlines but
you don't want to disclose any kind of
such data it's very very confidential
you can do that just in case of accident
serious accidents so this is Airbus 320
sketch of Airbus and there's an
important unit mounted on in its ends
called flight data acquisition in it and
this is the place where all the sensors
wiring is coming and from this unit by
using wires the data stored in the
aircraft black box what do you think
we're the I box is on this aircraft yeah
who said that
okay thank you so the flight data
recorder can be anywhere it's usually in
the tail section of the plane but now
the problem is we would like to analyze
that data and to find insights from the
data and see okay these pilots are not
doing these things properly but not the
pilots we don't want to blame the pilots
it's our operation how we set it okay
but the problem with this is that it
would be very expensive to you just take
the black box of the aircraft and to get
the data out and put it back so you
don't want to ground the aircraft but we
all we all live in the world very tight
profit margins in airline so you don't
want to grounded aircraft for that so we
have something else this is quick access
recorder it's a small thing device
mounted behind the crew in the cockpit
and it just uses the camera card to
collect the data it's completely the
same data that's coming to data
acquisition unit it just splits into two
bits and pieces the idea is that you can
easily just take out the the card and
upload it to a server and we can analyze
that data yeah
data acquisition is just electronic a
box that collects the signals you first
you have to collect the signals in one
place then you will distribute this by
wires to flight data recorder you have
to have thing that first you can't feed
the flight data recorder with all the
buyers 5,000 parameters of 2,000
parameters sorry so first you have to
condense these two thousand parameters
and then just use one buyer to put it
into flight data recorder okay so how we
do this the first you have to have an
aircraft flying taking off flying and
landing and the latest copy to service
it can be done automatically wirelessly
some airlines do that but you can also
as I told you you can just take out the
card and just upload the data on the
service then data cleansing oh there is
numpy master race there's some Python so
yeah okay and sorry but this is a very
very time-consuming process because and
you know that your data people so it can
take very very much time and then the
data is being analyzed by the software
it's in highest in-house software and
then we detect the events on the
aircraft so one of the events can be
hard landing so the crews just smashed
into the ground and there was a value of
two point zero g and passengers were not
so they will reluctant to say that that
was a smooth landing yeah yeah so we do
these kinds of things so but yeah this
is just to break the presentation into
two parts but since you've already had
lunch I put this one but by no chance
this is a I don't try to advertise Java
hear you say that so but it's everything
is written in Python ok up now I
promised you that I'm going to try to to
make a data analyst by data analyst of
you in just one minute so what I'm
showing you at the moment is the flight
profile this is the altitude profile and
you can see that at 351 the aircraft was
on the ground and it goes
up crews and landing okay now we see
that there is an event here around
quarter past five and i'm going to
enlarge the DX is i'm going to zoom in
that data so the shaded area is this
this area and i'm going to give you two
parameters airspeed and altitude and i
also i'm going to give you engine power
just disregard n1 it is dead the red
line is one engine the red green line is
the other engine what do you think it
happened here i'll give you 30 seconds
to do to 45 seconds time but what what
was the value minimum value of attitude
if no it's about 300 feet sorry for the
scale yes it went go around it was too
low altitude to say that they were w no
q3 cute you don't do that it's so such
low altitudes the lower to the ground
you are the rescue operation is so you
don't do these kinds of things it was
the go around so the what crew did it
just pushed the throttles up and
accelerated and there is another
parameter pitch so this is the angle
with respect to horizontal surface so
they're pitching up editing full power
above 100 and the aircraft goes up and
you can see these smooth lines so it's
not instantaneous then just need some
time to react to your commands in table
this is the data you will see that pitch
is 15.1 so it's mark at the red event
because you're not pitching in 15
degrees when you land usually want to go
stead in route down and the other thing
the engine power was above hundred
percent percentages normal values can be
fear above hundred percent but it's yeah
so it's it's yeah very much power put
into the system so this is an to
exceedance of just power exceedance and
this was marked as a go-round event and
in fact it was it go random and we don't
know from this data why it was it due to
bad by the weather or something else
this is what was this hopefully it's not
an engine of an aircraft yeah but this
is an old agricultural steam engine but
for those of you who like jet engines
there's a schema and since we all hear
from data land we can abstract those
things you don't have to know air space
dynamics of things that I blah blah to
understand this so the interesting bit
is just just look at the colors there is
a green colour shaft and it's called low
pressure shaft and it's characterized by
one number now rotation speed ok we are
abstracting the parameters there's
another one and two the purple one this
is the high high pressure shaft and you
have to put something so you were
putting your producing pressure in the
engine and then you have to put some
fuel and this fuel burns and you have
exhaust gas temperature to simplify
things i'm just going to disregard this
first two parameters because we are
going to play with the model with just
fuel flow and exhaust engine temperature
exhaust gas temperature temperature so
these two are in play if you have four
engines or to end yeah usually you have
to but if you have four engines then you
can keep pairs of parameters together so
now you have eight parameters you don't
have just two parameters so this
redundancy will help you to lower the
variance in the result what happens its
takeoff fuel flow is about 500 liters
per kilograms per hour and it's steady
there so probably aircraft is on the
ground you see pitches 0 so the slope is
0 just sitting at certain point it will
get to take a clearance from the ATC and
then when they get to take of clearance
that they will put some power to the
engines and you'll see some time needed
to put this to go up so fuel flow starts
here and goes up while they're
accelerating down the runway so you get
the maximum full flow but they're still
on the ground you said that pitch is 0
after that take off happens
approximately here then because pitch is
going up there pitching their rotating
ever up pitches the nose and goes up
the interesting baked hair after 20
seconds into the flight the crew presses
the V nav button so this is vertical
navigation yes some people think okay
who is flying the plane usually they
will just press the button and the
computer will try to adjust so they are
taking off because it's very risky to be
lowered to the ground and we still
believe humans are better for some some
people will not be on that but what its
pilot that pitches the aircraft at a
certain point he says okay computer take
over and the computer takes over what
happens as a result of that computer
thinks that it has to maintain lower or
higher speed and it will adjust the fuel
flow to have an optical performance take
off or whatever that means so in a few
seconds time in fact you will see this
drop in fuel flow because the computer
will try to accommodate for the new
situation and it happens just a few
seconds after the autopilot was engaged
and we want to detect this point okay
and it's a big problem if this point is
not detected probably will have a
provisional problem with the engine
health because during takeoff higher
values of power are allowed you are not
allowed to have one hundred percent
power in cruise okay so if you if you
just disregard this point then you might
miss the opportunity to see that
something is wrong how the engines are
handled so the parts are using too much
fuel too much power and you will have
they will have to go to maintenance too
early and this is losing money in fact
and compromising flight safety so it's
extremely difficult we try to do that
deterministically so with the classical
signal processing so differentiation of
signal the signals are very much
different and they vary across very
different aircraft families the problem
was what if parameter fails you have
eight parameters recording and helpers
aircraft and 105,000 approximately on 1
100 and 500 1500 parameters on airbus
380 and then you just can't it's the
parameters will fail but it's not that
the aircraft can't fly
okay so it happens all the time so we
have problems with missing data we have
to handle it very frequently and this
kind of you have to retrain the model
make it make a different model another
dependency tree if you if your parameter
fails if you don't use statistical
approach for that so the solution is
just use the V nav when the octopus was
engaged and try to find the drop or
raising fuel and exhaust gas temperature
and we'll try to find the changes around
those times to mark the point correctly
well gather the knowledge and try to
calculate the probability for the end of
table for an unseen flight so these
three parameters are in the game and now
ruff will continue with matt he asked me
before this presentation you just tell
two people that we are going to do some
Python so I just forgot so you'll have
to yeah
okay so as Mark introduced I will be
talking about the detection of the end
of the cough point how
how we're going to do this it's a rule
abusing properly they probably sink
approach and we will have a mortar that
is very insertive into part first part
is we've gone away probably stick
approach and in the second part we don't
have a data-driven approach essentially
we want to go back the probability
distribution from a number of flights
and then apply apply all the
probabilities that we have collected to
predict the end of the cough point for
the new testing flight what's the main
will going to be it's going to be of
course by donna and
okay it's going to be Python with the
sundered classical library is not by
step I psyche to learn and we're going
to use by MC so if you are for with any
course I need two dollars or any other
conference e any other the talks you
know a bit open sea I i can give i will
give a very short presentation of that
but first of all let's talk about the
data as Marco say that we have the data
in our server that is solid as an HD f
viola and in order to you to load the
data and export the data we use the our
flooded access so that is an open source
tool and it's for the command is on
guitar disease the a screenshot of the
documentation page as you see one main
point is about the master device and
that's it's very important
tool that we have your mask other ways
of telling us if someone if a certain
parameter is feeling and how many times
this parameter is feeling as an example
of what use our hdf our access there are
many ways you can subclass our hdf file
you can use the width heat that is very
pathological and you essentially
excessively does a normal but in
dictionary now all the data each
parameter is recorded at the different
frequency for example the normal G is
recorded eight samples four seconds
whereas the pitch is recorded a sample
per second before we have resolved to
align each of them and in this example
among each of them at frequency one and
this is an example of showing the beach
and a one and one that is the power of
the first engine and as you see before
the second 500 there is a piece of
missing data that's that happens not so
readily and when that happened we really
don't want to use depth data in order to
fit our probably sick modem
what's a strategy we have a as I said
before we are way to step model for Saul
we create our probability model we fit
the model so we collect the parameters
that we want we detect the vertical
navigation engaged and we just look for
a window around the vertical navigation
engagement brothers we know that the end
of the curve it will up and around that
point we run our modern collect samples
for each flight and then we will collect
all the samples and we use those sample
to predict the end of probability for
different flights why we have a
different a to start model because not
all the flights and the vertical
navigation and because sometimes the
vertical navigation may just fade as
parameters what happened sir
hold it go to the young just come and
look at the diaper clutch right now yeah
I went through the the JavaScript that
have been la da de jesús in the night
but we have to swap this so i probably
made the eye this is the old good job ok
that's fine so here I just want to
present a very simple model I we are
going to use just two parameters to flow
and excess custom which will four on one
engine and essentially what happen is at
around about 30 navigation those
parameters are a piecewise constant
there will be a drop at some point and
that rock will be precise viendo take
off so we want us and when that happens
the data that those parameters are time
serious we want to find the distribution
probability that each point is the end
of the cough point the ketone will be PI
MC that essentially is a very powerful
utility to run a markov chain monte
carlo methods to sample from a
statistical model well also the matter
does not work that
okay so since i don't have these i can
just show
that's all hopefully
and we apply Bayes theorem to computer
the posterior probability of our
parameter given the data now I don't
have the formula here but if you just
have in mind that we have a certain
probability of a number of parameter
given the data bye-bye serum that is
equal to can I just swap this
well why raise the formula so you don't
bother the people i know that's that was
just much
it
yes this is hello public programming
come home
the school that's amazing
okay so no
ooh
okay so we have our lists of parameters
that is the time point the fluid flow
airwave flow one in prefer to which
means the mean of the fluid from before
and after the end of the golfer and each
other and in digital society mean of the
egt before and after our Bayes theorem
is telling us that the posterior
probability it's essentially the product
of the likelihood that is probability of
the data given our parameters time
suppliers the probability of each
parameters now we model this in this way
we have the likelihood here I'm just
considering two parameters we F F 1 and
F F 2 and these the likelihood will be a
normal distribution that well the mean
is FF before the before the end of the
cough and after the end of the cough the
for the players who have the time stamp
the time point when it happens we don't
know when it happens we give for us it
can happen anytime between 71 and 720
remember that we have a 20 seconds wind
of around the vertical navigation and
the mean of the flow flow before and
after again this is signal we have
certain noise so we give us prior
distribution are a normal a normal
distribution with a mu equal the mean of
depending on the data the mean of the
flow that
feeling the data that we feel in the
model with when we take the egt into
play we will change our life hood to be
a product of one dimensional normal
distribution we consider the parameter
to happen to be independent to each
other and this essentially it can be
easily increased to multiple dimensions
we can have this for one engine for two
engines we will have a similar larger
than similar price this is an example of
how things work in a pion see I'm not
gonna go through this code line by line
this is just to say that that's the
class where I define my prior
probability and the likelihood
essentially as you see for example the
EDX represented Lee the time and it's a
description for more probability between
one and your length of the data which
would be 27 I can probably stress on how
you run the model around the sampling
this by MC 2 so year what they do is
creating a class and creating out my
data modeler just to be all the
variables that are defined in this class
if I'm see you create a model object and
then after that the NMC MC object from
where you simple this case we sample for
10,000 time the cell number
eight-thousand that is the pudding
period essentially at the end of the
sampling we will
ten thousand samples for each parameters
and we discarded the first 8002 is the
feeling which means essentially it's a
in itself to decrease the
autocorrelation the idea of the Markov
chain the MCM since the acronym for
markov chain monte carlo is essentially
doing a random work in multi-dimensional
space nothing is really random therefore
that can be a correlation and we want to
do this as much as possible that
therefore we run a wall model this
running plot is essentially a dropping
function whether I load the data I clean
the data in the sense that I detect the
vertical navigation and just take the
parameters around those 20 seconds data
points I run my two dimensional model
with the flow and egt and what they f is
this bunch of hazama each salami is
representing the samples that I collect
after the mcmc Rana so as you see that
is a very clear difference between the
full flow before and after as well as
dgt in this case sometimes it happens
you have that the posterior probability
is just weeks at 16 seconds all the same
forces are converging and on that number
and this is because in this case what we
have is that when we look at the full
flow that's the blue line know there are
very steep decrease of these parameters
while 4d GG here the scale I purchased
for that is it does not give the
messenger but there is a huge difference
between the before and after but the
other question is what happen if one
parameter feel we have a musket away we
can give a threshold if more than five
percent of this data is mascot then we
don't want to use that parameter we that
will be contaminating our model in this
case we can just run again our our our
model this is in one dimension we will
just be considering the full flow if for
example dgt face and these essentially
again the trace is plotted the system
and this is the same date as before so
it's not a surprise that again in 16
seconds now the second part of the model
it's about prediction we have a new
flight and we don't get if there is the
vertical navigation kilometer or not we
just want to look at the first five
minutes from the take-off to 7500
because we know that the end of the Gulf
must happen in in the first five minutes
so what we do is running the mcmc in
number of flights 200 in in this
instance and we collect all those
samples in order to use them for
debating apart now I've run my mother
four hundred flights and this is the
distribution of the full flow before and
after as well as egt before and after
and the in the third line edx absolute
first graph here for system it's
representing the end of take off the
distribution of the end of the offer
from the
from the deck off point so 30 seconds
after the takeoff so what's this I shall
use these samples well again we apply
Bayes theorem so basically I'm is
selling out said that if I want to come
if I want to check if a data point is
what's the probability that a data point
is and the end of the gov I just have to
compute these products so the likelihood
that will be the end of the cough given
my parameters and the prior will be
given by our prior knowledge on the
parameter that will be the time the for
flowing digiti and precisely the
likelihood will be used that will be
infrared from the our history
so in this example we have no we don't
really know when the end of the coffee
it's happening we know that for sure it
cannot happen in the first 15 seconds
it's just too early so for the time we
have a discrete uniform distribution
between 15 sevens and 304 the foot flu
initiative again we give a normal
private distribution for the likelihood
we will use that we use the data in this
case I'm just showing how to out of a a
probability density function from our
kiss from in this case we use cyber it
starts the Gaussian kernel density
estimation for ear we can use a cycle or
not again we can use another one of the
mcmc again but for production purposes
this is the fastest this is a fastest
one and this an example what happened
for a forgiving flight here that the
rear end of the cough is at 41 sevens
and essentially we computed this
probability at each point in time from
the take-off up to five minutes and we
see that the prediction is around the 42
seconds which essentially we can use
also this data to assess somewhere no
previous model we can run this
prediction algorithm on all the data or
all the flights that we use it to fit a
model and we can have some
magix to assess that model I'm not
showing that here for because of the
time I guess I'm already over going so
if you have any questions software
developer probably also data science
academy and are now and yes for the
primacy reference that is a it's really
good that the actual documentation of
primacy and I strongly advise you the
base and meet us for our help i can
reduce speed 0 that is actual so Open
Serena the multiple failures of
interpreter yeah and you're talking
about detecting undertaken and G
calculate other features as well and for
example determining repression trim or
incorrectly wait its place you have to
increase the range of velocity higher
than your expected because you
you have depending on what you're trying
to achieve you can do that and there
there's thing called a directed take off
but in fact the fruit doesn't set you
can't see this you can't see the drop in
fee for people going on it is straight
line why they use it there are reasons
for that but the idea is to make a long
story short is that we will not in that
case be able probably to detect this
point because we will be fitting the
noise but we can always snap to the old
tradition of heart threshold of 300
seconds and say if you reach 300 seconds
and we will grant are able to detect
that point but 600 seconds is a limit
and we have another linen it's 3,500
feet so if you reach they have 350 bit
you should have gone over the veena
order enough tables for it as the passer
but very good point there are many many
parameters that depend on long yeah it's
what about Malaysian plans normally does
the temporary recorder also contain the
the black voice recorder as well as a
point Dave important that's a very good
question I know some people who try to
do something with the cockpit voice
recorder but still if this data is not
being analyzed about since we don't use
it if they're probably janata my estate
sites we can look at and probably
provide only a couple of files the
problem sir it's very hard to the
identified those flights so and the key
to the keep of energy usually don't eat
week sometimes we can but sometimes the
identification is harder than you think
because you can say no but you know
knowing a lot longer lot you know what
for which everybody took off and if you
know the airline you can have just one
ever tried to that Airport Greenland
somebody you know who wrote that line
and sometimes it's very very hard to do
that you said they release it sometimes
in case of accident just in case of that
accidents and for regular maintains that
you didn't you take off the API black
box from the aircraft but all those
pictures available for download no good
thing we are also doing some data
sharing programs where ms will share
their data we don't have unfortunate the
time to talk about that these are very
interesting concepts but for the sake of
flight safety and I scare group together
and share their data so the pilots have
the prior knowledge of how to fly the
plane but if you could gets into an
unknown a nap airport you will be able
to know the issues in that level so he
will be
do you respond to do it to the
requirement of land because it's easy to
say land and air prevalence it's not so
easy when it's dark outside and you have
stumblings blowing my side it's
challenging it's the peanut botany
Presley not recorded at all yes it is
yes easy you that Franklin yes we use
the veena for referencing the point of
arrives we start from there to find that
the drop-in fuels log that we detectors
end of clean air entering price yes this
is just a binary variable 01 some why we
have many many many more categorical
variables then you know then we have
continuous continues animal variants
somali not seem to be that you're
sometimes the winner is corrupted the
pilot signal may be corrupted sometimes
it does not exist at all not on the
night of the aircraft way of the veena
button for me recorded that that signal
or the gravity can be no
okay why is this data safe confidential
it seems like you know you can throw a
website where you can go on crack planes
taking off and landing in real time why
would things like beautiful OB be super
confidential no it's not just a few for
it's the data in Europe you have how
many countries and every single country
has a body that regulates the safety so
you have civil aviation authorities that
regulate how the data in whose data is
in fact the data Chris can help me who
have in Germany I think that the pilots
all or all the data and problems with
the rest of the European if you take few
clear example so there is commercial
problem so you've got one Operator
device with high fuel flow than another
and suddenly you know that operators
able to compare his operations I'm not
operate and say you know what we can do
this Jeep or we can do this for fiction
doesn't it come back now it seems like
it hi yeah it seems like this would be a
public value yeah yeah it gets over here
is it just like commercial no no no
thalia come people there oh my source
start bleeding a respect to save Tenth
Circuit with respect to safety things
video Kasasa that you can download our
algorithms that we've used in production
but the data we don't tow the data we
parameters and calculations that we
gather from the date so it's it's
readily available but all the
technologies that we use our open source
for space SQL or Python I don't know how
all these kinds of things by the data is
dallas won issues probably they you
mentioned that you don't want to be
blaming toilet yes so if you open up the
data once well as the products make
trust you not to blame them if they open
up at the end of the rest of the world
how would we do those work you are gues
all realize this is yeah but you know I
appreciate ya you just nobody was to try
to fly and happen and you do not have
any pilots because they they already
know that they have been monitored
because we legal requirement is that
they have running the APM program so now
when you start you know sharing the data
across the globe for the good of it's
not an easy process and they're very
traditional in aviation that's where
they have checklists and the safety is
really but your point is great I mean
yeah we would like to do that but the
only way we can listen through data
sharing programs where they do that
voluntarily are not press it I was other
any airlines that they cannot protect no
not that I know I've
yeah thank you more questions they can
discuss a break in your life
thank you very much for coming nice